sous la direction musicale de David
Stern et sa compagnie opéra Foucault le
Théâtre de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
présente le 7 juin un concert des airs
les plus emblématiques de Mozart
interprété par 250 enfants
issus d'école primaire et collèges des
Yvelines il devienne le temps d'une
représentation de vrais choristes j'aime
bien chanter je trouve que c'est bien en
plus on apprend plein de champs et c'est
facile à apprendre on commence à aller
répéter puis après on les approche chez
nous de temps en temps dans ma chambre
je chante un peu d'opéra comme ça
peu habituer à écouter des airs d'opéra
nos jeunes chanteurs travaillent depuis
plusieurs mois enchaînent répétition en
classe et sur la scène du Grand Théâtre
un projet qui demande un réel
investissement on arrive dans avec des
enfants sur des secteurs difficiles et
qui sont qui deviennent passionnés et
voilà ça vient aussi de l'enseignant qui
est très très moteur dans une dans une
classe on leur a expliqué l'histoire de
chacun d'opéra ils sont venus au théâtre
c'est bien aussi qu'on vienne dans leur
milieu ils sont contents qu'on vienne
dans leur classe et il nous montre aussi
tout travail qu'ils ont fait autour de
Mozart en l'occurrence pour cette année
non c'est passionnant
les enfants sont motivés ça fédère le
groupe
ils deviennent beaucoup plus concentrés
ils sont attentifs ils sont attentifs au
moindre petites remarques donc ça en
classe pour les apprentissages c'est
apporte beaucoup curieusement même si
les paroles sont en italien en allemand
ils ont eu beaucoup de facilité à les
apprendre plus que l'étape de
multiplication ou les conjugaisons
à partir du moment où ils sont dans le
projet et qui sont heureux d'y
participer ils ont une faculté de
mémoriser beaucoup plus que les adultes
ça passe tout seul la mise en place de
ce projet et pour le théâtre l'occasion
de démocratiser l'accès à l'art lyrique
dans le cadre de son programme opéra
pour tous
soyez généreux d'accord c'est généreux
faites-le pour le public pour vous pour
objectif étant évidemment au travers de
ce projet de faire des jeunes gens des
spectateurs avertis avant tout c'est de
leur donner des clés pour apprécier au
mieux les œuvres et les œuvres d'opéra
notamment et et évidemment l'idée
l'objectif c'est d'en faire de de futurs
spectateurs de futures spectateurs
autonome dans leur pratique on pourrait
imaginer et c'est le cas année après
année on se rend compte que nombre
d'enfants reviennent avec leurs parents
dans une pratique individuelle une
pratique de plaisir de loisirs et on est
ravi